an increasing number of sickeningly
violent crimes is being committed by
america's youth
why is this happening is it a spiritual
problem family breakdown problem is it a
cultural problem policing problem
or is it a combination of all of them
well the stories the criminality seems
to be getting worse
two iowa teens have just been accused of
killing their 66 year old high school
spanish teacher with a baseball bat
in minneapolis earlier this month a 17
year old was charged with shooting and
killing a man
while he sat in his car at a gas station
and last month a 19 year old was
arrested for the murder of a
nine-year-old girl there
now back in january the star tribune
editorial board warned fear of random
violent crime is growing in the twin
cities residents have been attacked at
various times of the day in communities
across the metro authorities have traced
most of these frightening cases to teens
as young as 13.
joining me now is john turnip seed
former gang leader drug dealer and pimp
he's also the executive vice president
of urban ventures john
why is this happening you're based in
minneapolis we always think of minnesota
nice but what's driving the violence
well one of the things this is sort of
the aftermath of george floyd you know
when that happened and all the
lawlessness came in
kids got a sense of empowerment
and you know all of a sudden we're
backing off you know
arresting people for certain things and
things of that nature well kids you know
who have a rebel spirit in the many ways
a lot of times take advantage of this
and now it's it's uh sweeping the
country and kids will follow trends at
one time we had kids that would knock
people out see if they could knock
people out with one blow so this
carjacking thing is really scary because
it's all across the nation
and it's sort of like a badge of honor
now that these kids and they know that
their first offense nothing will happen
to them
how much was the shutdown during covid
also a driver of some of this where
kids were out of school sometimes for
long periods of time
forced to not socialize with each other
i'm not saying that's an excuse but that
couldn't have helped an already
precarious dynamic
that's that's correct kids got when the
shutdown happened kids got more time to
spend with kids and sometimes that's a
really bad situation where kids have too
much time to spend with other kids and
they get bored and whatever and all of a
sudden they try to think of something to
do something exciting something that
they can do that just makes them so cool
you know and part of the in-crowd sort
of say so yeah covet and being out of
school
hurts tremendously
how about fatherlessness how does that
affect this
father absence i think is the biggest
problem we have in the nation i think if
every father went and claimed their kids
and fathered their kids and disciplined
their kids we wouldn't have all the
problems that we have today john thank
you for your experience personal
experience and your insights tonight hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else